hi and welcome to my video series of
piyo techniques explained in five
minutes where I explain a concept of
piyo techniques in less than five
minutes or so if you haven't yet
subscribe the channel hit that subscribe
button why are you waiting for my
lectures are also present in Han Academy
which is India's biggest learning
platform in order to avail my lecture
you can use my code AP 10 which would
give you 10% discount so today's topic
is radial immuno diffusion let's learn
about it so this is a method by which we
can roughly quantify what is the
concentration of antigen in a patient
sample or enough fluid in order to
perform that we need a particular petri
dish which is already coated with agar
now in that petri dish there would be
antibodies distributed all over against
the antigen which we want to measure
so the antibodies are all over the place
inside the spectra dish now inside that
there is a well where we are going to
put the patient derived sample or our
Sam sample antigen which need to be
determined
now after putting the antigen the
antigen would start diffusing out from
the well in all the direction in a
radial fashion right now let's look at
the antigen and antibody interaction in
a graphical format now before that let
me tell you that in the situation where
the antigen and antibody ratio is a
equivalent ratio and the equivalence is
reached then what happens is there is a
precipitation band or precipitation
radius is forming like this now here we
are going to talk about the antigen
antibody amount and how the
precipitation would look like or what
type what type of interaction would be
there so when there is excess of antigen
there is no precipitation because there
is too less antibody and this is the
situation very close to the well now in
the zone of equivalence there is a
perfect ratio between antigen and
antibody such that this precipitation
reaction can take place and a feasible
precipitate can form
and there is an antibody access zone
which is far away from the well where
there is more antibodies less antigen
so again precipitation does not take
place so precipitation take place in the
zone of equivalence when there is a
ratiometric balance between the antigen
and antibody and this is the key aspect
of this test so how we can use it in
order to use that first we have to load
some controls so in this coated slide
where we have all the antibodies there
we are putting three standard samples of
an antigen of known concentration we
were first putting known concentration
and then we are putting a patient
derived sample and try to measure what
is the concentration of it and as a
result of putting the antigen in this
wails it would diffuse radially and form
a precipitation ring and this pretty
[ __ ] precipitation rings radius can be
measured now we have known standards
which which are previously known the
concentration of antigen and looking at
the test antigen which was a patient
derived sample we can roughly have an
idea that what is the concentration so
from this particular example you can see
the test antigen concentration is
somewhere between the antigen that is
present in the first and the second well
so that is how we get a very crude and
rough idea about how much antigen is
present in the sample but honestly this
technique these days has no validity
first of all it is qualitative not so
quantitative we have very good
techniques such as Eliza such as radial
immunity few radio immunoassays and all
of these things so this particular
technique is pretty old but that time it
was good so we kind of learned about the
basic principles behind the technique
and if you know want to know more about
the Eliza and more about radial immunity
immunoassay I have other videos on that
so do click on the link at the end of
this video so thanks for watching if you
like this video give it a quick thumbs
up don't forget to Like share and
subscribe thank you